as some ccsd students get ready to
return to the classroom next week
some leaders in north las vegas want
ccsd superintendent dr jesus jarrah to
bring back
extracurriculars as well bianca holman
joins us live now with the push to
return to sports hi bianca
at most parks across the valley
basketball hoops are missing like the
ones here at desert horizons park
now this was done in an effort to
discourage
contact sports and to encourage social
distancing during the pandemic but north
las vegas leaders want the clark county
school district to bring back sports and
extracurricular activities
city council woman pamela goins-brown
spoke about the increased suicides among
youth
and the police chief pamela ojeda she
highlighted the
increased carjackings involving teens
both say sports give us
students a positive and structured
outlet student athletes also spoke about
the missed scholarship opportunities to
pay for college
and the emotional impact of zero social
interaction with peers
i landed in southern utah but this whole
kobe thing messed up a lot of offers for
me
i was talking to the university of texas
and unfortunately it did not fall
through
so i settled for less but i'm still
going to work through it so on emotional
health it has taken a toll because
when you play with your team like you
become a family
and so there are many districts around
the country that are allowing high
school sports arizona reinstated winter
sports in january
and l.a county just met the covet
threshold to allow youth sports
to resume now i reached out to the
school district to see if there was a
response for dr
jesus jarrah they say that there will be
a press conference in an
hour that's at 1 pm that has an
opportunity to address some of these
questions
reporting live in north las vegas bianca
holman 8 news now